the following is a conversation with
John mimer a professor at University of
Chicago and one of the most influential
and controversial thinkers in the world
he teaches speaks and writes about the
nature of power and War on the global
stage in history and
today please allow me to say once again
my hope for this little journey I'm
on I will speak to everyone on all sides
with compassion with empathy and with
backbone I will speak with Vladimir
Putin and with Vadim zalinski with
Russians and with ukrainians with
Israelis and with Palestinians with
everyone my goal is to do whatever small
part I can to decrease the amount of
suffering in the world by trying to
reveal our common
Humanity I believe that that in the end
Truth and Love
wins I will get attacked for being naive
for being a shill for being
weak I am none of those things but I do
make mistakes and I will get
better I love you
all